>> Eddie: YOU HAVE PATRICK KANE
BY THE DUCKS' DEREK GRANT.  OF
THE MINNESOTA WILD.
1616E SIMON AND DRYSDALE WITH
A BLOCK, AND TAKEN BY CALEZONE,
AND ACROSS THE ICE FOR RADDYSH
AND HE SHOOTS AN SHOT.
>> Eddie: WATCH AT WHAT IS
ENDING UD THE PASS FROM ROBINSO
FIND CARRICK AND THE DUCKS TIE,T
IS A 1-1 GAME.
>> Keith: I AGRE
ARE --
>> Kenny: NOW A EWS DID DID A
IT, AND IT WAS A TOUGH NIGHT,
AND ONE NIGHT L LOOK AT THIS
ON SIMONEASE, AND THIS IS CARRI
Eddie: HERE'S THE GOOD HIT BY
GERRY MAYHEW, AND HEO IS ONE FO
ONE.
AND PATRICK KANE IS WITH THE
PUCK, AND OUT  AND THE KANE IS
H
IMPORTANT,D BETWEEN THE
LEGS OF JOHN GIBSON WHTHE STOP.
>> Eddie: WHAT A PAS
QUALITY ONES INSIDE OF THE DOTS
LANKINEN, AND THE SHOTS ART
GRANT AND ACROSS THE BOARDS ANC
>> Eddie: LOOK AT THIS BEHIND E
THE NET.
>> Eddie: IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS
SHOT OUT OF THK AND
TOEWS WHO ARE THE CENTERMEN ON
THE FACE-OFF, AND CARRICK WITH
BACK TO  PLACED.
STROME BEAEA
>> Kenny: NICE PLAY BY JONES.
LEADING TO
TOEWS MOVING THE PUCD OFF OF TH
ONE OF THE 50-50 P P